some breaking news in Scotland's next
leader has just been announced Yusuf
Hamza has won the Scottish national
party's leadership contest and is set to
become Scotland's first Minister the
election race was triggered after
Nicholas surgeon abruptly resigned as
the leader of the Scottish national
party in February live to Nadine Baba in
Edinburgh Nadeem so he was a clear
favorite and he's now been declared the
winner Yusuf Hamza
that's right you can hear see Hamza
Yusuf behind me he's just said that he
feels like the most the luckiest man in
the world now that he is going to lead
the party that he joined 20 years ago
has paid tribute to his rivals in this
leadership Campaign which has been a
bitter campaign and made it clear
divisions within the Scottish national
party since Nicholas sturgeon said she
was going to step down for example he's
the only of the candidates who said that
he would still try to challenge the UK
government which has been blocking the
Scottish government's gender recognition
Reform Bill which basically makes it
amazing for transgender people to
self-identified he's seen as a
continuity candidate some people thought
that might actually stand against him
because there has been a push for in
some areas radical ideas but in other
areas people perhaps more socially
conservative
things like abortion and equal marriage
so for now the challenge for him is
going to be rallying the party behind
him
right we're going to talk about the
challenges in a bit we're just going to
listen in Nadeem uh to uh Hamza Yusuf uh
who's speaking right now Hamza use of
the new uh Scottish national party
leader to also find opportunity
my government will seize the economic
and social opportunity that the journey
to Net Zero will bring a country is
energy rich as Scotland should not have
people living in fuel poverty the
government I lead will renew and
redouble our efforts to lift people out
of poverty to make work fair to make our
economy work for the people and to
ensure as we become a more prosperous
country we also become a fairer country
too
and while I have had my fair share of
battles with the UK government over the
years and there may well be some to come
I will work with him and other devolved
Nations constructively where I can in
the best interests of our nation
I'm a pro Scot an equally a proud
European too and Scotland is a European
nation we want to return to the European
Union and play our part in building a
continent that's based on human rights
on peace prosperity and social justice
to the people of Scotland the SNP has
earned your trust by governing will by
ensuring that your priorities are our
priorities as a party and as a
government we are at our best when we
are radical and Bold and the challenges
we face today they require nothing less
of us
that is what I promised the people of
Scotland if parliament of course puts
its trust in me tomorrow
joining the SNP for me was an act of
Hope all right it comes our use of
giving his first speech after winning
the Scottish national party leadership
contest he is now set to become
Scotland's first prime minister Nadeem
Baba is there for us listening in as
well so we have a new party leader what
will be his priorities what are going to
be the challenges
[Music]
well there are several of very large
challenges obviously the first obviously
the resonator of this party the Scottish
national party is delivering
Independence Yusuf has made it clear
that unlike Nicola sturgeon who said
last year that she wanted to use any
election in Scotland as a de facto
referendum on Independence he said
that's not really a practical solution
he prefers a gradualist approach
building up more support because opinion
is very divided here in Scotland in 2014
of course they voted no things that were
more finely balanced at the moment he's
also made it clear that his party stands
for uh for Scotland being a European
nation and returning to the European
Union that's a reminder that Scotland
voted as a whole against brexit so
that's another big challenge how to move
towards that goal in the coming years
he's talked about social justice he is
somebody who very much believes in the
progress of policies that Nicola
sturgeon brought forward on things like
climate and things like um equal
marriage on things as well like the
gender
recognition Reform Bill he is very much
committed to that but it's not clear
whether that's going to go anywhere with
the UK government blocking it at the
moment as the UK is blocking the idea of
a referendum let's not forget that last
year the Supreme Court told Scotland it
could not hold a referendum without the
backing of the United Kingdom government
Nadeem thank you for that Nadeem Baba
with the latest there from Edinburgh
where Hamza Yusuf has just been elected
the new leader of the Scottish national
party and will become Scotland's first
minister